ان ان نتابع الاخبار العاجله التي وردت
قبل قليل وتظهر الان على شاشتنا اداره
الطيران الفيدرالي الامريكي تقول بانها
تسعى للسيطره على عطل فنيا في نظام
الاشعارات الجويه اثر بل اثر على عمليه
الطيران في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اداره طيران الفيدراليه الامريكيه قالت
ايضا ان الطلاعات في كل انحاء البلاد
تاثرت بالاعطال في النظام وانهم يعملون
على استعاداتها وكلار ترانس للانباء الشرط
ايضا الى ان مطاراتي باريس الدوليه تتوقع
تاخيرا في رحلاتها على خلفيه الاعطال في
انظمه حواسيب الطيران الامريكيه
وما زلنا اذا نتابع عبر هذه
تقول طلبنا من شركات الطيران ايقاف كل
الرحلات الداخليه حتى الساعه 9:00 صباحا
في التوقيت المحلي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الان هي الساعه السابعه و 25
دقيقه صباحا بتوقيت الساحل الشرقي في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه شركه يونايتد
الامريكيه تقول نظام الطيران الفيدرالي
ارسل اشعارات بوجود مخاطر وقيود على
الطيران في الوقت الحالي
او واحد من المطارات الامريكيه صور مباشره
لعدد من الطائرات الرابطه في ارضيه المطار
ربما توقفت جل هذه الرحلات نتيجه هذه
الاعطال في نظام الاشعارات الجويه
ستتاثر اذا حركه الطيران الامريكيه همم
التاثير الطالع ايضا مطارات باريس
وكاله رويترز الانباء بان الرحلات تاخرت
على خلفيه هذه الاعطال في انظمه حواسيب
الطيران الامريكيه
اا لدينا مزيد من المتابعه مع مراسلتنا من
واشنطن بيسان ابو كويك بيسان ما اخر ما
اعلن بخصوص هذه الاعطال وتاثيرها على حركه
الطيران
نعم اخر المعلومات هي اعلان اداره الطيران
المدني انها ما زالت تعمل على
استعاده اجهزه الاخطار هذه الاجهزه التي
همم
الطيارين وربان الطياره
وترقامها باي معلومات حول العمليات على
الارض او اي اخطار محرقه لذا هناك عطل
طبعا فني في اجهزتها وما زالت تعمل على
استعاده هذه الاجهزه وانها امرت جميع
شركات الطيران
بوقف الرحلات الداخليه
واي طلعات لا رحلات داخليه حتى الساعه
9:00 صباحا بعد ساعه ونصف من الان حتى يتم
التاكد من صحه وسلامه المعلومات طبعا كان
هناك ايضا مع اعلان ايضا من اداره طيران
المدنيه قبل ذلك القول ان بعض همم بعض
الامور باتت تعود الى العمل ولكن يبدو
انها همم وظائف بسيطه جدا وانا الامر لم
يحل حتى الان وزير النقل الامريكي بيت
بوتاجاز قال في تغريده بانه على تواصل مع
اداره وهيئه الطيران المدنيه حول هذا
العطل الذي يؤثر على الاجهزه ويوفر
المعلومات معلومات السلامه والامن لتواقم
التيارات وانا تعمل على حلها بشكل سريع
وامن لاستعاده العمليات طبعا وافقه همم
المعلومات طبعا همم
الجهات التي ترصد تحركات الطائرات اكثر من
1000 همم رحله تم تجمي تم يعني تاجيلها
وتجميدها داخل الولايات المتحده اما رحلات
خارجه او داخل الى
الاجواء الامريكيه او رحلات داخليه
بالاضافه الى تجميد عدد من الطائرات وحتى
الغاء عدد من الرحلات المحليه حتى هذه
اللحظه يعني وفقه التحليلات التي يتم
تداولها لا يوجد همم يعني من الامور التي
ينظر او يتم النظر اليها ان كان هناك همم
ربما عمليات قرصنه او اا او ان ما حدث هو
نتيجه قيام جهه خارجيه ربما حتى يعني
محاوله للقرصنه او تعطيل حتى اللحظه كل
المعلومات التشير الى انها ضاع عطل في
الاجهزه وانه لا يوجد اي امر مريب او انه
تم تم فعل همم فاعل طبعا القضيه ما زال
متفاعله
هل هي سابقه الذي اول مره يحصل هذا الفني
في مطارات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مثلا
بهذا الشكل يعني جلال
يطال جميع الرحلات على مستوى الولايات
المتحده منذ الحين والاخر يكون ربما في
اعطال متعلقه بمطارات
معينه وما الى ذلك ولكن يعني في التاريخ
القريب لم نسمع بامر مشابه لما حدث اليوم
على مستوى الولايات المتحده
برمتها طبعا هي قضيه ما زالت كما ذكرت
متفاعله وما زلنا ربما ننتظر كل التحديثات
التي تاتي حول الامر يعني ما حدث هو انا
مصدر كان همم
سر هذه المعلومه لشبكات ام بي سي قبل ان
تؤكد اداره الطيران المدنيه الامر وكما
نرى من صور عده مطارات الركاب داخل تلك
المطارات طبعا ينتظرون انفراج هذه الازمه
وطبعا تاثيرات على الطيران ليس في
الولايات المتحده ولكن حتى خارجها بما ان
الرحلات الخارجه من واشنطن او عفوا من
الولايات المتحده ايضا
تم تاجيلها هناك رحلات كانت قد طبعا همم
حين حدث هذا كانت في الجو ما مصيرها همم
ربما نحاول ان نستطلع هذه الجزئيه تحديدا
خصوصا ان هذا العطل يؤثر على اجهزه
الاختبارات الداخليه وما بين المطارات
وتواقم الطيرات وهي طبعا في الاجواء يؤثر
اذا على اجهزه الاخطارات كما ذكرت بيسان
ربما سندخل في امور نوعا ما تقنيه وفقه
المتوفر من المعلومات بيسان ما الذي اعلن
عن طبيعه هذا الخلل وكيف تسبب بشكل مباشر
في هذا الارباب في المطارات ورحلات
الطيران
يعني ما هي الجوانب التي
هو عطل في اجهزه
الحواسيب في اجهزه الكمبيوتر التي
والبرمجه التي تتحكم بجهاز الاخطار هذا
مما يؤدي وفق ما توفر من معلومات الى
تعطيل توفير المعلومات اللازمه
للطائرات لاجهزه لتواقم الطائرات وهي في
في الاجواء كان قبل
انطلاقها او مغادره تلك الرحلات او قبله
هبوطها وهي في الجو هذا ما يعني همم
بتحديدا ذكرته اداره
او اداره او هيئه الطيران المدنيه انه فشل
في اجهزه الكمبيوتر او الحواسيب
وطالا الجهاز
والبرمجيات برمتها لذا يتم الان استعاده
همم عمل هذه الاجهزه او كما يقال تحديدا
في اللغه الانجليزيه
التي تتحكم بهذه الاجهزه يعني ليس عطل همم
يعني ليس عطل مادي اا وصفه ما تم تداوله
حتى الان وسيله بيانات سميحيه لمواقع رست
حركه الطيران اا تشير بان اجمالي عدد
الرحلات المتاخره داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وخارجها بلغ
11230 رحله حتى الساعه وبيسان طبعا
مصير الرحلات التي هي في الاجواء الان
سنحاول ان نستطلع هذا لاحقا طبعا
تلاحظون في العواجل بان هناك تاخير في
جميع مطارات الولايات المتحده بطلب من
اداره الطيران الفدراليه التي عمت على
جميع شركات الطيران بان تؤجل اقلاع وهبوط
الرحلات من والى مطاراتها في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
ايضا رويترز كما اسلفنا كانت اشارت الى ان
مطارات باريس الدوليه تتوقع تاخيرا في
رحلته على خلفيه الاعطال في انظمه حواسيب
الطيران الامريكيه نور الدين بوزيان ينضم
الينا من باريس نور الدين هل لديكم
معلومات
جلال المعلومات
[موسيقى]
كبير قبل لحظات تتحدث الى المتحدثه
الرسميه باسم مطارات باريس فاكدت لي اولا
بان هذا مشكل تقني يتعلق بالجهه الامريكيه
وليس الجهه الفرنسيه ثانيا اكدت لي بانه
لا توجد رحلات ستلغى من الاراضي الفرنسيه
وانما سيجري تاجيل عدد كبير من الرحلات
المبرمجه اليوم سالتها كم عدد هذه الرحلات
لم تشاء الاجابه وحولتني على جهه اخرى هي
المسؤوله عن نظام الرحلات كل ما هو معروف
انه بين الولايات المتحده وفرنس
سلام سنعود اليك بعد قليل فقط
سنتابع تتابع معنا هذه الخريطه لحركه
الطيران في الاجواء الامريكيه وفقه ما
يشار اليه في هذه الصور وما يلاحظ طبعا
على هذه الصور التي نشاهدها الان على
المباشر لهذه الخريطه همم هو توقف لهذه
الرحلات
المعلقه والمتوقفه الى الساعه همم التاسعه
صباحا بتوقيت الامريكي
كما اعلن لكن هذا العطل الفنيه الذي طال
نظام الاشعارات الجويه اكثر على حركه
الطيران من داخل وخارج الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وقال ايضا الرحلات في المطارات
الدوليه في العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس ما زلنا اذا نشاهد هذه الصوره
لخارطه توضع حركه الطيران المتوقفه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مثل ما اسلفنا
وبيانات
حيه لمواقع رصد حركه الطيران تتحدث عن ان
اجمالي عدد الرحلات التي الغيت داخل
امريكا وخارجها بلغ مئه
وثلاثه رحلات كما نقرا